i'm a vegas poll worker and we're sick
of this [__]
the ballots are right [__] here and
we're counting we're not
doing anything shady
we're not doing anything wrong [__]
the biden campaign
came over a little [__] help
and we're just [__] we know we're
burning the midnight oil
this is one for trump
the binding campaign said if a ballot
looks like it was completed by a nazi
and you can tell that then we're not
able to include it trump
trump this has a b on it i'm just going
to write i didn't
this isn't a ballot this is a grocery
list
but i just wrote kamala harris's name on
it
so this is one for joe
one two ballots for joe
three ballots for joe
this is a ballot for joe biden
so this is 300 000 votes for joseph
barton
i hope they open [__] up soon